hey everyone it's stephanie wong back
again i'm a cloud developer advocate and
i am thrilled because we have eric
brewer our google fellow here with me
again today we are doing a series of
videos and we are talking about google
kubernetes engine for next-gen
developers eric welcome back great to be
here thank you i want to talk about some
of the most common questions that both
you and i and i think a lot of us here
at google cloud have gotten the first
being what is the difference between
kubernetes that is google kubernetes
engine in particular and serverless
well they're both the future so in that
sense they're easy to get confused
but i would say the main difference is
kubernetes and gke in particular are
really great platform for building a
wide range of services and that's really
the key you can build all kinds of
services on top of kubernetes and gke
server-less
especially classically defined obviously
means no servers but it usually means
functions as a service or request reply
patterns in particular
websites and so
that is an example one of many of a kind
of domain specific solution and in
general when you have a domain solution
like cloud run you could do a fantastic
job for that domain
that is much easier to use than
kubernetes
so if you know exactly what you want to
do and it's opinionated and it's narrow
you should build that as a platform as a
service
if you're going to build all kinds of
things like your enterprise kubernetes
is the great base for that in fact i see
lots of enterprises building internal
platforms as a service of various kinds
on top of kubernetes and that
combination makes a huge amount of sense
okay so it sounds like if you have a
specific use case that serverless
products are well equipped for
then absolutely go with that
but
what about in the case where you might
start with a serverless product like
cloud run cloud functions et cetera and
then you decide later on that you know
we are fully bought into kubernetes and
we would like to broaden our use cases
we want to build platforms on top is it
possible to sort of have both in your
environment uh lots of customers use
both today in various interesting
combinations
uh there are certainly customers that
started out on app engine or cloud run
and moved to kubernetes because they
want finer grain control over all the
details that's one reason and in fact
they're rebuilding kind of a customized
platform internally for themselves
there are other groups that use
something like cloud run for the front
end services and use kubernetes for
back-end services that also makes a lot
of sense because you can do a lot of
data management control in kubernetes
there are groups i know of at least one
that uses both for a different reason
which is they have a kubernetes cluster
that does their main
load but when they have you know hotspot
like a black friday and they actually
use cloud run to absorb the spikes and
so there's lots of ways to make this
work
really depending on what kind of
cleverness you want to play to mix these
together but they're definitely they
work well together and you can start on
cloud run and move to kubernetes later
is a really common path
well here's the thought
so we've talked about this a little bit
in our previous videos about how
platform teams want to use kubernetes
and yet they also want to customize
their platforms for their needs
we talked about policy enforcement as an
example so how should an enterprise use
kubernetes engine
well in general a
a cloud provider
offers more things that you really would
like your developers to use and what i
mean by that is if you're an enterprise
you have a platform team
uh and you say oh we're building this
kind of financial service
we really don't want to give our interim
developers
all possible abilities like we don't
really want them to be in charge of
their own credit card transactions for
example because that's a highly
regulated thing it needs to be done very
carefully with careful audit logs and so
really what i'd like to do is give my
internal developers a platform where
they can do credit card transactions
that are guaranteed by the structure of
the services to be compliant with all
regulations and by the way in all
different countries in which we operate
and so i see kubernetes is the way to
build these customized platforms where
they enforce whatever rules the
enterprise cares about through things
like control over project creation
control over the nodes you use control
over the os you use control over the
libraries and repos you pull from right
those kinds of background controls are
things that are not typically up to the
internal developers to decide
but at the same time provide some
services framework possibly something
like anthro service mesh to manage
services across these things and give
their developers again the productivity
that you want
and the velocity of features but again
in a way that's decoupled from risk
around certain features that are highly
regulated
especially yeah and it sounds like there
is very much a culture and
organizational structure in place in
which you have your
operators and administrators and your
developers
now we do have a lot of curiosity out
there in the community about you know
advice for these next generation of
kubernetes developers and we've actually
collected some of them uh i know that
you threw out a prompt for ama questions
on your twitter and so did i so get
excited everyone we are going to come
back in the next video with a handful of
those questions so stay tuned and thank
you so much eric looking forward to it
thank you
[Music]